digamos que tenemos el siguiente
polinomio que es 16 x cúbica más 24 x
cuadrada más 9 x muy bien entonces el
objetivo de este vídeo será factorizar
tanto como se pueda este polinomio así
que te invito a que hagas una pausa y
trates de hacerlo por tu propia cuenta
bueno vamos a intentar nosotros a
factorizar este polinomio y la primera
idea que uno puede digamos utilizar es
factorizar x verdad porque podemos ver
que tenemos x un término x en estos tres
sumandos verdad y también podríamos
preguntarnos si podemos factorizar algún
número pero vemos que entre el 16 el 24
y el 9 no tenemos ningún divisor en
común verdad para los tres entonces sólo
vamos a factorizar x verdad y esto va a
multiplicar a 16 x cuadrada para que nos
dé 16 x cúbica más 24 x para que nos dé
24 x cuadrada más 9 muy bien ahora
podemos observar lo siguiente esto es
bastante interesante verdad porque
tenemos cuadrados 16 x cuadrada en
realidad es 4 x al cuadrado verdad y 9
es 3 al cuadrado así que esto lo podemos
reescribir
un poquito más abajo lo podemos
reescribir como x que multiplica verdad
primero consideremos este término será
4x elevado al cuadrado verdad y también
podemos observar que este 9 en realidad
es 3 elevado al cuadrado muy bien
entonces ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es fijarnos en 24 x y lo voy a escribir
de la siguiente forma esto será dos
veces que multiplica a cuatro y que
multiplica a tres verdad por x por equis
entonces esto en realidad se ajusta muy
bien al patrón de los trinomios
cuadrados perfectos que hemos visto en
otros vídeos verdad por ejemplo si
teníamos
y eso lo eleva vamos al cuadrado verdad
lo elevamos al cuadrado esto en realidad
nos daba lo mismo que a x elevado al
cuadrado más dos veces a por b por equis
más b elevado al cuadrado entonces aquí
claramente podemos ver que este 4x
corresponde a nuestro a nuestro x
cuadrada verdad bueno 4 x cuadrada
corresponde a este x cuadrada verdad y
podemos ver que este 3 al cuadrado
corresponde a nuestro b cuadrada del
patrón que habíamos observado en vídeos
anteriores verdad entonces esto que
tenemos en el paréntesis lo podemos
factorizar como un binomio elevado al
cuadrado verdad en este caso a vale 4
entonces tendremos 4x
ve que en este caso serían tres y todo
esto va elevado al cuadrado
todo eso va elevado al cuadrado y no hay
que olvidar que teníamos una x factor'
izada aquí afuera verdad entonces aquí
tenemos ya una factorización de este
polinomio con el que habíamos iniciado
también podríamos haber escrito x por 4
x 3 x 4 x + 3 pero bueno eso se
simplifica como 4 x + 3
elevado al cuadrado así que la clave fue
primero factorizar lo que se pudiera
factorizar verdad en este caso sólo era
x y luego notamos que el restante era un
trinomio cuadrado perfecto usando el
patrón que vimos en los otros vídeos